pleased to present this citation and
praise of reaching up to you and welcome
any comments you wish to give the
graduate president tole vice chairman
Griswold Dean Schultz pastor Q to
Marshall ëthey alumni president BB
honored guests distinguished faculty the
Board of Governors Lum nigh family
friends of course the class of 1999
thank you very much for honoring
reaching up with this generous citation
for inviting me to your graduation
ceremony I had a little epiphany this
morning walking around this wonderful
place the Magnificent setting the
talented student body the accomplished
faculty thought here I've named my
magazine after you you have this nice
town called Kennedy Ville just down the
road thinking why didn't I go to
Washington College I have this sneaking
suspicion I was invited here as much for
the fact that like all of you
a certain man by the name of Washington
looms large in our life as for the
accomplishments of reaching out
I think perhaps mr. General Washington
would been more pleased with the toils
you have completed in his name than mine
and it's daunting to be in the
presidents of a such a distinguished
scholars besser Higginbotham who as you
know is a world renowned expert on
George Washington himself Thomas
Jefferson though endlessly admiring of
Washington found him a little heavy
going so I'm not sure he would so I'm
sure General Washington would have
deemed our political magazine a bit of
an unseemly mockery but to all of you
congratulations you have accomplished
something the great man George never did
you are a college graduate
and believe it or not he went on to do
great things in politics without ever
having to become a lawyer and by being
conspicuously spare with words his an
org Euler address of the 1797 was the
shortest given by any president a mere
126 words but don't keep constrained by
the seeming perfection of his example he
was a human and was afflicted by many of
the miseries that attend those who
choose a life in public service he was
publicly spurned by a woman he courted
Betsy Fauntleroy who thought that he
wasn't rich enough his opponents seek
that ceaselessly circulated rumors about
his illegitimate children including
Alexander Hamilton and and he was
plagued by an embarrassing presidential
relative his mother Mary Ball Washington
who falsely complained to whoever would
listen that she was destitute and
neglected by her son and he was on
occasion excoriated by his opponents for
padding his expense account but enough
about him today is your day and I hope
it's just one of the many that define
who you are
what you make with your life at
Washington College you have availed
yourself of a liberal arts education in
other words you have learned how to
learn and having chosen a college with
an international student body you've
gotten to know people who are different
from yourself and who have been enriched
by the diversity of that experience
you've also benefited from Washington's
historic mission to shape Future Leaders
you have recognized your obligation to
share your talent with others you have
cleaned up beaches and put out fires I'm
told you have tutored at-risk children
and given them time attention Good
Counsel and friendship you've taught
Special Olympics kids to swim
volunteered at camp fairly Manor and
held the senior citizens ball at a
nursing home you've rolled up your
sleeves alongside the faculty and staff
4kc time the college's annual day-long
community service effort
Thomas Paine said youth is the seed time
of good habits individuals and in
Nations you have played a vital part in
your community and I know that your good
work will not end with graduation now I
should tell you something about the
organization that you have so kindly and
generously acknowledged here today ten
years ago jeffrey sachs and i somewhere
in the audience founded reaching up in
order to improve educational and career
opportunities for the workers in health
education and social service the
frontline workers those who teach and
care for people with disabilities and
children with special needs
disadvantaged youth the chronically ill
the frail and elderly typically
entry-level care givers received
virtually no training and earn just
above the minimum wage they have few
prospects for advancement and are more
likely to leave their jobs and to stay
more often than not to flipping burgers
into McDonald's or Burger King because
that pays them a lot more money than
being a direct care worker reaching up
in the City University of New York
joined together in a partnership to
create opportunities for thousands of
direct care workers to enroll in
job-related courses that could lead to
undergraduate degrees through our
Fellows Program we have also provided
college scholarships and career
mentoring to four hundred exemplary
workers since nineteen ninety not since
nineteen ninety half of them have
graduated with baccalaureate or Master
degree a quarter have completed
certificates or associate degrees and
more importantly ninety-five percent of
them are still employed in those jobs
many of those who've completed their
education have become social workers
teachers and psychologists and some are
even run the human service agencies they
once served in such a lowly capacity
with what this means it's the most
valuable vulnerable people in our
society receive better care and support
the families feel more secure employers
experience less turnover and caregivers
are better trained better compensated
and better appreciated the colleges
where they study gain from there were
real-world experiences and are enliven
the families of direct care workers are
not struggling as hard to make ends meet
their children have also benefited many
are attending the best colleges in the
country no doubt many of you know what
it means when I say that service is its
own reward and I hope that you continue
to serve for me working with reaching up
has been a tremendously rewarding
experience I've learned a great deal
from it you have learned a great deal at
this college but your learning must
continue to be a lifelong experience
that is informed by your direct
involvement in the lives of your fellow
citizens as George Washington wrote
dozens of times over and over to
practice his penmanship when he was a
young man labor to keep alive in your
breast that little spark of celestial
fire called conscience thank you very
much for this honor and good luck